NUMBERS BEGINNING TO LEVEL OUT
AND FILL PETER IN MIAMI,
THANK YOU AS ALWAYS.
OF THE LATEST INFORMATION
TONIGHT FROM DR. ANTHONY FAUCI
AND THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND COULD TO
SEO.
AS FILM AND TRYING TO COME OUT
PHASE THREE TRIALS OF THIS
MODERNA VACCINE BEGAN 6:45 WITH
PATIENTS GETTING WHAT WILL BE
ONE OF TWO SHOTS IN 28 DAYS
APART AND WILL YOU BE LOOKING AT
DURING THE PHASE THREE TRIALS?
>> THE PHASE THREE TRIALS, JOHN,
THE MAJOR QUESTION IS THAT
DOESN’T WORK?
IS IT EFFECTIVE?
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR AND OBVIOUSLY YOU
WANT TO LOOK FOR SAFETY CONCERNS
ALSO BUT THE ISSUE HERE, YOU
VACCINATE 15,000 PEOPLE WHO GET
THE VACCINE, 15,000 WILL GET A
PLACEBO AND THEN YOU DETERMINE
THE DIFFERENCE IN INFECTION WITH
A CORONAVIRUS IN EACH OF THOSE
GROUPS.
IT’S A TWO ON STUDY AS YOU SAID,
CORRECTLY, IT’S A TRIAL FOLLOWED
BY A BOOST TO 28 DAYS LATER.
HOPEFULLY WITHIN A PERIOD OF A
FEW MONTHS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
GET A SIGNAL TO KNOW WHETHER IT
ACTUALLY IS EFFECTIVE IN
PREVENTING INFECTION WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS.
IT’S EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCE,
JOHN, BECAUSE THIS IS THE
FASTEST WE HAVE EVER GONE FROM
THE IDENTIFICATION OF A NEW
VIRUS AND DOING THE SEQUENCE,
GETTING THE VACCINE, GOING INTO
PHASE THREE TRIAL FOR EFFICACY.
BY INCREASED TECHNOLOGY THAT’S
REALLY BEEN TRANSFORMING THE WAY
WE DO VACCINE TRIALS.
>> John: NECESSITY IS THE
MOTHER OF ALL INVENTION AND
BASED ON THE INITIAL DATA, HOME
OPTIMISTIC ARE YOU YOU’LL GET
WHAT YOU’RE LOOKING FOR FROM THE
MODERNA VACCINE?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE RESULTS
FROM THE PHASE ONE TRIAL, ALBEIT
A RELATIVELY SMALL NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS, THE VACCINE INDUCED
IN THOSE INDIVIDUALS A LEVEL OF
ANTIBODY NEUTRALIZING ANTIBODY
WHICH IS THE HALLMARK OF
PROTECTION, THE LEVELS THAT WERE
AT LEAST AS GOOD AND IN SOME
CASES BETTER THAN YOU WOULD SEE
FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE
CONVALESCENT FROM NATURAL
INFECTION.
EVEN THOUGH THE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE WERE SMALL, THE FACT THAT
YOU CAN INDUCE A RESPONSE THEN
MIMICS WHAT YOU DO WITH NATURAL
INFECTION IS GOOD NEWS.
THAT MAKES ME CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE MAY HAVE
SOMETHING HERE BUT IT WILL TAKE
A FEW MONTHS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT WE DO.
>> John: EARLY DAYS AT THE
VACCINE DEVELOPING, THE
GOVERNMENT WAS GOING TO DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY HERE AND IT
WAS GOING TO PROACTIVELY START
TO BUILD UP A SUPPLY IN THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT THAT
EARLIER TODAY AND LET’S LISTEN
TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> WHERE MASS-PRODUCING ALL OF
THE MOST PROMISING VACCINE
CANDIDATES IN ADVANCE SO THAT ON
THE DAY 1 THAT IT’S APPROVED, IT
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY AND
WE WILL PROBABLY HAVE A LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD, THE WORLD IS SUFFERING
FROM THIS CHINA VIRUS.
AS WE MENTIONED, IT’S A
DEPARTURE FROM THE WAY THINGS
NORMALLY ARE AFTER PHASE THREE
TRIALS ARE OVER AND THEN YOU’VE
AND THAT WILL GET IT OUT THERE Q
PEOPLE HAVE THE QUESTION AS TO
WHO WILL GET IT FIRST.
>> IS A GOOD QUESTION, JOHN,
WHAT WERE GOING TO DO AND WERE
GOING TO TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY
AND THERE’S COMMITTEES THAT ARE
FORMED TO GET THE RECOMMENDATION
OF GETTING THE VACCINE OUT
EQUITABLY TO THE PEOPLE WHO
BENEFIT FROM IT MOST AND THAT’S
NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU TAKE
LIGHTLY.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS THAT THEY
WILL BE OUR PRIORITIZATION AND
HOPEFULLY AS WE GET INTO 2021,
JOHN, WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH
VACCINE FOR EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS
IT.
EARLY ON WHEN YOU FIRST TO START
DISTRIBUTING IT, WE’RE NOT GOING
TO HAVE EVERYONE AND WHAT WILL
DO HIS WILL PROBABLY HAVE PEOPLE
WHO COULD BENEFIT THE MOST AND
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE AN
EXAMPLE, FIRST RESPONDERS AND
THE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE PUTTING
THEMSELVES AT REST AND TAKING
CARE OF PATIENTS WITH COVID-19.
THERE WAS WHO ARE VULNERABLE,
THE ELDERLY, THOSE WITH
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS BECAUSE WE
KNOW NOW FROM THAT EXPERIENCE
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO HAVE A SERIOUS NEGATIVE
OUTCOME FROM INFECTION.
>> John: PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKED ABOUT GETTING THE FIRST
SHOTS AND NECK, SEPTEMBER, IS
THIS GOING TO BE A OCTOBER
SURPRISE AND POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
AND HERE’S WHAT THE SECRETARY OF
HHS ALEX AZAR SAID ABOUT IT
EARLIER.
>> THERE’S NO POLITICS IN ANY OF
THIS AND WE NEED THERAPEUTICS
AND VACCINES AND WE NEED THEM AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN GET THEM AND
WE ARE WORKING TO BASICALLY
SHAVE EVERY DAY OF THE
DEVELOPMENT AND MANUFACTURING
THAT WE CAN DO AND THAT WE CAN
DO SO.
WE’RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY THERAPEUTIC OR ANY VACCINE
IS SAFE AND EFFECTIVE UP TO THE
FDA GOLD STANDARDS.
>> John: DR. FAUCI, YOU WANT
TO GET A VACCINE OUT THERE AND
IT IS THEIR POLITICAL PRESSURE
TO GET THIS OUT THERE BEFORE
NOVEMBER THE THIRD AND ARE THERE
ANY CORNERS BEING CUT IN ORDER
TO DO THAT?
>> THERE’S NO CORNERS BEING
CAUGHT AND I GUARANTEE YOU THAT
AND SAFETY IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS NOT
COMPROMISING SAFETY AND
CERTAINLY NOT COMPROMISING
SCIENTIFIC INTEGRITY.
IN FACT, WE BRIEF THE
PRESIDENT TODAY ABOUT THIS IN
THE OVAL OFFICE AND THERE’S NO
POLITICAL PRESSURE THAT I HAVE
SEEN AT ALL TO MOVE QUICKLY.
THE SPEED OF THE TRIAL AND HOW
QUICKLY YOU GET THE RESULTS IS
DEPENDENT UPON CERTAIN FACTORS.
ONE IS THE NUMBER OF INFECTIONS
THAT YOU GET WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF THE TRIAL TO DETERMINE IF IT
WORKS OR NOT.
IF WE GO OUT THERE WERE GOING TO
HAVE 30,000 PEOPLE IN THE TRIAL,
15,000 GET THE VACCINE, 15,000
WILL BE PLACEBO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ACCRUAL AND
THE RATE OF ACCRUAL THAT YOU
COULD PROJECT YOU GET AN ANSWER
SOMETIME IN THE MID-TO-LATE
FALL, THAT WOULD BE SEPTEMBER,
IT’S VERY DIFFICULT TO PREDICT
AND IT WILL BE THE INFECTION
RATE AND THE PEOPLE WHO GET
VACCINATED, ARE THEY IN THE
GROUP.
>> John: DR. FAUCI, 30 SECONDS
LEFT AND THEY MENTION IT’S THE
BEGINNING OF THE PLATEAUING OF
SOME OF THE SPIKES THAT WE HAVE
SEEN AND STATES LIKE TEXAS,
ARIZONA, FLORIDA.
WOULD YOU THINK IS RESPONSIBLE
AND DOES NOT BODE WELL FOR NOT
HAVING TO ROLL BACK THE
REOPENING THAT WE HAVE SEEN?
>> CERTAINLY YOU LIKE TO SEE
WHEN YOU GET SURGES LIKE THAT
WHICH ARE VERY DISTURBING, JOHN,
YOU BEGIN TO SEE THEM PLATEAU
AND THAT MEANS HOPEFULLY PEOPLE
ARE STARTING TO DO THE
FUNDAMENTAL THINGS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING THEM TO DO ABOUT
MASK WEARING, AVOIDING CROWDS,
CLOSING THE BARS YOU KNOW, HAND
HYGIENE, ET CETERA.
HOPEFULLY, I BELIEVE IT IS NOW
HAVING AN IMPACT AND YOU’VE GOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OTHER STATES
ARE STARTING TO SHOW A UPTAKE
AND DO WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
BEFORE YOU GET THE MAJOR SURGE,
OTHERWISE, WE WILL BE REPEATING
WHAT WE SAW IN SOME OF THE
SOUTHERN STATES WHICH WOULD
REALLY BE A SHAME IF THAT
HAPPENS.
>> John: EVERYBODY HAS TO DO
THEIR PART AND WE SHOULD MENTION
WE TALK WITH YOU LAST WEEK ABOUT
YOUR DEBUT THROWING OUT THE
FIRST PITCH AND WE’VE GOT A
FRAME OF THAT AT THE
NATIONALS PARK AND WE SHOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THAT YOU NOW HAVE
THE TOP SELLING BASEBALL CARD IN
HISTORY.
51,512 CARD SOLD IN 24 HOURS AND
THERE’S THE CARD FROM THE TOP IN
50 YEARS FROM NOW YOU COULD BE